[Música]
hermano del macro ni marine lepén
volverán a enfrentarse por la
presidencia de francia ambos pasaron a
la segunda vuelta que se celebrará el
próximo 24 de abril el mandatario se
hizo con el 27 6% de los votos frente al
23 por ciento de su contrincante de
extrema derecha según las estimaciones
de ipsos opr asteria para france 24
múltiples ataques contra ucrania en una
nueva jornada de la guerra este domingo
las tropas rusas atacaron el aeropuerto
de mi pro
severodonezk quedó prácticamente en
ruinas y otra serie de ofensivas se
registraron en ciudades como heart
kimiko life
según los resultados del conteo rápido
en méxico más del 90 por ciento de los
electores votó porque el presidente
andrés manuel lópez obrador permanezca
en el cargo los mexicanos celebraron
este domingo una consulta de revocatoria
del mandatario promovida por el propio
presidente y que contó con una baja
participación
hola bienvenidos a una nueva emisión de
noticias en france 24 los saluda andrés
meza muñoz
empezamos en francia que enfrentará un
reñido balotaje el próximo 24 de abril
esto después de que el mandatario
francés emmanuel macrón y la
ultraderechista marine lepén encabezarán
la primera vuelta de las elecciones
presidenciales con los partidos
tradicionales fuera de la primera línea
política a sus candidatos apelan al voto
por macrón para impedir que la
ultraderecha llegue al palacio del
elíseo
un escenario que ya se vivía en francia
hace cinco años de un lado el actual
presidente manuel ma con con el 27 6 de
los votos según los resultados
proyectados
quiere una francia que se inscriba en
una europa fuerte que siga formando
alianzas con las grandes democracias
para defenderse no una francia que salió
de europa que tendría como únicos
aliados a los populistas y xenófobos
internacionales esos no somos nosotros
son el otro lado la ultraderechista
marine lepén que logró un 23 por ciento
aumentando el número de votantes
respecto a las presidenciales de 2017
lo que estará en juego el 24 de abril no
sueles un voto de conveniencia sino una
elección de sociedad e incluso de
civilización nación en tercer lugar el
izquierdista jean luc mélenchon quedó al
0.8 por ciento de distancia de su rival
lepén llamó a sus votantes a realizar un
cordón sanitario a la extrema derecha
no deben darle un solo voto a la señora
lp lo sé lo repetiré porque a veces
cuando digo cosas es como si no las
dijera
así que lo digo de nuevo en esta parte
de la película en este pasaje no debemos
dar ni un solo voto a la señora lepe
en los partidos tradicionales franceses
se quedan fuera del mapa político de la
segunda vuelta pero tanto los
socialistas los verdes como el
conservador partido de los republicanos
cerraron filas a favor de manuel ma con
robots que votaría conciencia a emanuel
macrón para evitar la llegada al poder
de marín la peña y el caos que supondría
resultó realizar pero vio a los votantes
verdes que bloqueen la extrema derecha
votando por emanuel macrón el 24 de
abril julio por su parte el
ultraderechista eric se move que
sorprendió con el 72 por ciento de los
votos apeló a sus electores a votar por
le pen
[Aplausos]
no dudó de quién es el adversario por
eso hago un llamado a mis seguidores
para que voten por marine le pen por la
reñida segunda vuelta del próximo 24 de
abril será una repetición del último
encuentro electoral de 2017 los
ciudadanos estuvieron menos interesados
en esta campaña electoral en comparación
con la última y esto se vio reflejado en
la participación de estos comicios que
fue casi de un 65 por ciento un dato
menor al reportado en 2017 y es que
otras noticias han ocupado los titulares
en francia una de ellas es
indiscutiblemente la guerra en ucrania
pero hay otras preocupaciones que se
esconden detrás de este desinterés
[Aplausos]
a medida que iniciaba el 2022 los medios
de comunicación de toda francia se
preparaban para una sola cosa las
presidenciales pero resultó que el
presidente de otro país ocupó todos los
titulares sobre el snem por eso he
hablado con el presidente macro ya pudo
ver entre sí más tiempo tres naciones y
línea nazi de hablaré con todos los que
deba hasta que nuestro pueblo sea libre
antes de la invasión rusia ucrania
alrededor de una cuarta parte de los
franceses no tenían interés en las
elecciones y la guerra le relegó aún más
a un segundo plano
los índices de aceptación de manuel
macro se dispararon cuando asumió el
papel de mediador internacional y al
retrasar la confirmación de su
candidatura rechazó los llamados de
otros candidatos para debatir un momento
preciso para un hombre que ha intentado
transformar su imagen desde las últimas
elecciones de novato político a jefe de
estado fiable
durante los cinco años del mandato de
macrón se ha librado continuamente y de
forma bastante oportuna del centro de la
política francesa
cautivando a los moderados de los
republicanos y del partido socialista y
ha montado un partido que es muy eficaz
en el gobierno pero que no despierta las
pasiones políticas psicológico
pero en lugar de convertirse en una
figura unificadora macrón demostró lo
contrario las protestas masivas marcaron
la primera mitad de su mandato y
respondió lanzando una serie de
discusiones y debates en todo el país
pero todo esto quedó de lado por la
pandemia seguido por el paquete de
recuperación económica de 100 mil
millones de euros que implementó
[Música]
incluso cosas como el movimiento de los
chalecos amarillos cuyo fruto fue el
gran debate pero dónde quedó eso
hablamos de grandes debates y luego no
hacemos nada al respecto así que en
realidad resulta que la gente de arriba
está decidiendo finalmente así que creo
que hay un desencanto comprensible con
nuestra capacidad como ciudadanos para
tener un impacto en la política
kasab el impacto de la división en ambos
lados de la política francesa no
contribuyó apaciguar el desencanto sobre
todo porque muchos votantes sintieron
que sus principales preocupaciones el
costo de la vida la sanidad y el medio
ambiente fueron ampliamente ignorados
durante la campaña todas son promesas
bonitas y nada de acciones no confío en
ninguno de ellos este creciente malestar
se ha reflejado en los índices de
abstención la participación en francia-
lleva cayendo desde el 2007 y alcanzó
mínimos históricos en las elecciones
regionales del año pasado
cambiamos de tema y vamos a ucrania
varias personas resultaron heridas en
los ataques realizados por moscú este
sábado contra el aeropuerto de dmi pero
también fue atacada lugansk allí la
ciudad de ese perdón y es que quedó
prácticamente destruida por el fuego de
artillería ruso melissa chaves rincón
con los detalles
esta columna de humo sale del aeropuerto
ucraniano de ny pro el gobernador dijo
que las fuerzas rusas destruyeron
completamente las instalaciones y la
infraestructura cercana ante el primer
ataque los servicios de emergencia se
activaron mientras que los funcionarios
apagaban el fuego
rusia arremetió con más misiles como
resultado del ataque se desató un
incendio en un área de 100 metros
cuadrados uno de los misiles golpeó
además el pueblo de sant y ski
en la región de lugansk la
infraestructura de la ciudad de civil o
donges quedó prácticamente en ruinas
luego que el ejército ruso abriera fuego
en toda la ciudad además se registraron
ataques en kharkiv y mykolaiv en esa
misma región la unidad de artillería
ucraniana se prepara para defenderse con
parte de los suministros militares
entregados por occidente
estoy muy agradecido y quiero decirles
que no se detengan con sus ayudas
realmente las necesitamos
y vi lo que sucedió en crematorio es
inmoral nos vengaremos hasta el último
aliento por los civiles pacíficos por
nuestros hijos
luego que el primer ministro británico
boris johnson asegurará que brindarán
más asistencia económica y militar a
kiev rusia advirtió este sábado que
podría avanzar en una confrontación
directa con los países occidentales si
eeuu continúa abasteciendo a ucrania con
armas y municiones
méxico votó en la consulta de revocación
del mandato del presidente andrés manuel
lópez obrador y que fue impulsada por el
mismo mandatario según los resultados de
conteo rápido más del 90 por ciento de
los votantes decidió que se quede en la
presidencia previamente nuestro
corresponsal -mario carbonell nos envió
el siguiente reporte desde la capital
mexicana
en efecto se tienen los resultados del
conteo rápido que es un ejercicio
estadístico confiable que organiza la
autoridad electoral y bueno arrojo que
una participación de entre el 17 y el
18.2 por ciento de los ciudadanos
inscritos en la lista nominal recordar
que para que los resultados fueran
vinculantes tendría que haber
participado 40 por ciento de esta lista
fueron entre 15 entre 17 y 18.2 esto
implica una cantidad de entre 15 y 17
millones de ciudadanos los que acudieron
a votar de ellos quienes inclinaron
porque se le revoca el mandato a lópez
obrador por pérdida de la confianza
fueron entre 6.4 y 7.8 y en contraste
quienes optaron porque siguen la
presidencia fueron entre 90.3 y 90 y 1.9
por ciento
hubo en la jornada 1700 incidentes el
43% de ellos quedó resuelto y la
autoridad electoral calificó como un
éxito esta consulta dijo que cualquier
intento de descalificar lo sería un
despropósito toda vez que pues la
ciudadanía aportó todo todo su esfuerzo
hasta que está informativa en france 24
gracias por acompañarnos
[Música]